à faire une taille ou 30 ans est ce que
comme toutes les filles de 30 ans vous
avez marre des coups d'un soir mais bon
temps en temps un mec c'est bien aussi
moi j'ai trouvé l'homme de ma vie donc
les coups d'un soir ça ne regarde plus
et c'est comme toutes les filles de 30
ans et un ami gay pour vous accompagner
dans les magasins un mickey mais comme
tout est de 30 ans vous avez un ami gay
pour vous accompagner dans les magasins
oui je suis pas particulièrement des
copines un ami c'est con cette question
est ce que comme toutes les filles de 30
ans une expérience avec une copine
non ça t'emmerde bah oui qu'est ce que
tu fais c'est pour le prochain album
mais j'adore les hommes puisque comme
toutes les filles de 30 ans vous
attendez une demande en mariage que l'on
attend le bus non non c'est comme toutes
les filles de 30 ans j'ai déjà tout
essayé en amour et en sexe c'était la
même question que tout à l'heure tu
tourne toujours autour du sexe ça nous
énerve sur place que je peux dire tant
il ya des chansons aussi sur l'ennui sur
la boulimie sur la route
et toujours cette filière j'ai comme
toutes les filles de 30 ans vous adorez
parler qu avec vos copines en bouffant
des sushis j'adore oui au bouffon quoi
des sujets ouais ouais pourraient
disqualifier des trente ans elle mange
des sushis c'est tendance c'est une
question par dû me poser est-ce que tout
comme vous plais fille de 30 ans tu veux
répondre d' alors je te le faire à tout
alors je suis venue des filles de 30 ans
joey vous n'envisagez pas l'amour sans
un cunnilingus avant
deep et à rennes je fabrique les images
est ce que comme toutes les filles de 30
ans je commençais à vouloir éteindre la
lumière avant de faire l'amour a surtout
pas monter comme je suis surtout pas
j'ai envie que j'ai peur quand tu as
c'est vachement important pour moi joey
est ce que comme toutes les filles de 30
ans et à votre top sexuellement mais
c'est déprimant ne pas en profiter et
finalement soit c'est déprimant j'en
profite pas effectivement
est ce que comme toutes les filles de 30
ans joey vous êtes t'acheter un sextoy
pour les longues soirées d'hiver service
que je t'ai roduit atteint si tu fais
pas savoir comme je trouvais alors
écoute
non mais en parler de la série c'est
comme toutes les filles de 30 ans vous
rappelez des ex l'histoire de déprime
moi quand je déprime j'habite tout
change et c'est comme toutes les filles
de 36 ans avait prévu une liposuccion
cet été écoute je commence à reprendre
un peu de brioches pourquoi pas ouvert
aux marques tant que j'ai le jeu de
jambes ça me dérange pas rama a besoin
dit paul huchon est ce que comme toutes
les filles de 30 ans que penser que le
botox finalement c'est pas mal mais où
fort bien
est ce que comme tout début de 30 ans et
10 à vous rentrez le ventre quand vous
êtes à poil avec un mec ouais j'ai un
ventre très plein avant de voir prend le
livret va pas et tu verras m'en veux est
ce que comme toutes les filles de 30 ans
fait sans devoir être heureuse ah non
mais non justement je dis toute la
vérité rien que la vérité je le jure
maintenant ah oui mais venté cascua il
est comment ce mec alors celui qui est
responsable de la transformation il est
comment
c'est bien qu'il